was war dein schlimmster albtraum
schwierig ich habe immer ich habe kasse
albträume teilweise
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
mutiger spielen wir
gerd daun aufregend es ist mal wieder
spät es maria late und ich lieber wieder
minecraft und den boxer aus dem weg und
hat den kompromiss her bekommen sehr gut
so muss es sein ein comeback für papa 89
noch 1 com blog für mama und noch einen
finden oder es klappt so down liste
können blogger in die komplette sehne
dann geht es direkt ab dann drehe ich
durch ihn mit mir schwarz vor augen
nein ich war zwar auch mal ein kirchen
tunnelblick wenn ich komplett dann gibt
kriege absoluten tollen blick also kein
mäßig läuft es nicht immer besser als
eine gut dafür ist aber schon der
nächste alter der call blog hand ist
warm und da unten sind noch mehr alter
das könnte eine richtig krasse runde
werther fragt er fährt noch nicht
sterben ich habe jetzt schon 500 points
aber jedes gefühl da wirklich einer
finnischen deswegen mache ich mal lieber
ein bisschen pronto hiermit den
kompletten kann ich dir noch mitnehmen
steht einfach so als dieses webdesign
buyout die ice möglich ist sehr speziell
muss ich sagen guck mal hier mal da
immer so kranke drops auf diesen ordner
so richtig alter richtig dubstep niveau
komme ich an den einkommen nieder
heute ist so schmerzhaft
ich hab gerade auf tour sein aufruf
gestartet ob wir vielleicht ein paar
fragen habt die man in diesem berühmten
mal beantworten könnte hier kurz darauf
schauen ob ihr wisst schon was ein
gewartet habt welche videos schaust du
am liebsten fragt die turner t8 momentan
schaue ich am liebsten casey meister so
die blogs von dem guten mann wobei ich
auch sagen muss dass ich selbst die
nicht so wirklich konsequent suchte also
ich hab immer so phasen
also ich hatte mal eine phase da habe
ich geale place von dehner geschaut
damals war sie beim ersten semester an
der uni habe ich das jeden abend gesucht
wie man was zu essen gehabt mich das
bett gesetzt und dann das gespielt dann
ganz wiederum eine phase da habe ich die
alten herren games folgen von msi
experten stege gesucht warum auch immer
so ich dachte mir einfach okay diese
hießen einfach geil die muss man jetzt
alle durch schauen dann habe ich
wahrscheinlich auch fast alle angeschaut
weil immer nur die mit mci experten
stehe weil alle anderen war nicht so
cool war ja ja ich weiß nicht wer das
gefühl kennt zu dieser allianz folgen zu
suchten dann einfach so könnte das
nachvollziehen es macht einfach klick im
kopf und dann hat man auf einmal die
ganzen sachen drin und auf einmal weiß
man dann dass man jetzt die experten
muss und diesen sprung überlebt
regeneration oder slice und damit fahren
jetzt bisschen accor unter und sage
allerdings verpacke ohne mal resistenz
ja ok easy peasy mit return resistenz
praxis natürlich sehr schön die jam sind
wir auf 1.100 coins zum ende der zweiten
runde
das ist nice alter wir die fragen rein
knallt water for peace ist es viertel
vor zwölf aber richtig krass für diese
uhrzeit silberkurs 14 fragt bist du eher
nach der nachtaktive oder früh schläfer
also leute jetzt mal eine kleine kleinen
weg zu mir auf jeden fall auf jeden fall
nach aktiver mensch
ich bin abends viel produktiver ich kann
abends am besten sport machen ich bin
auf jeden fall nachtaktiv wollte ich
gehe unter der woche eigentlich immer so
um 3 ins bett und dann halt morgens um
neun wien zombie aus dem den laden zu
kriechen die werde auch in den letzten
wochen
dadurch dass ich hier immer vollzeit
arbeite und dann abends immer noch
videos mache und wenig schlaf habe
wirklich erst abends wach es kommt mir
wirklich so vor dass ich ins büro gehe
und mich hinsetze und denke so eine
stunde vergangen und es in acht stunden
vergangen und der arbeitstag ist rum was
cool ist zugegebenermaßen weil ich nicht
das gefühl habe dass ich irgendwie lange
im büro sitzen würde
aber andererseits ist dann halt auch wir
sind auch wirklich acht stunden
vergangen so und der tag ist
größtenteils schon wieder rum was dann
doch wieder bisschen komisch ist aber
alles in allem geht es schon
ich freue mich darauf wenn wieder
studieren kann wenn ich ein bisschen
mehr schlafen kann es wird gut
momentan ist jetzt auch nicht schlimm
also ich freue mich halt mich richtig
doll dass es mit youtube momentan so gut
läuft dass echten kracher stimmungs kues
für mich weil ja wenn man einfach so
viel zeiten das ist wirklich mal wieder
ein ehrlicher und wichtiger satz wenn
man so viel zeit in youtube reinsteckt
dann ist es egal ob man sich ob man
jetzt sich selbst einreden dass einem
klicks oder so nicht wichtig denn man so
viel zeit reinstecken youtube und so
viel energie in seinem leben schon darin
investiert hat dann ist das nicht egal
wie das ankommt was man macht würde ich
zumindest sagen als so geht es mir aber
jetzt muss man echt mal hier
zack zack zack schnell einkaufen hier
noch am reisen schwert und jetzt beim
supreme enchantment hier drauf bitte
irgendwas geil das ja egal das ist er
also das ist falsch samstag wird das
mifi respekt 2 am breaking respekt 2 ist
aber alles andere so war ein bisschen
was ich kann mir aber einfach noch ein
zweites kaufen so und zwar 123 jetzt
kann ich wieder max in kärnten ich komme
einfach noch ein eisen schwert junge
dieses luxuslebens habe ich gekauft
jetzt können das wir für drei
entscheidende etwas besseres mit vier
noch becken
das holz nach
hier sagt zack zack zack zack okay gut
jetzt nochmals alles klar deathmatch
startet wir haben unser respekt zwei
schwert wir haben eine ganz heiße
portman rüstung so gut gekürzt hat
wettlauf ist genau das was du nicht
machen da es mit dem schwert weil ich
ein 4 2 drauf habe es heißt brains bis
zum sankt nimmerleinstag
ob du es willst oder nicht und jetzt
kriegst du noch was und ich werde gleich
mal richtig getötet haben umfrage mit
reinnehmen hallo kann immer sterben kann
immer stärker gefragt wieso stirbt der
junge nicht der brend kontinuierlich die
ganze zeit was ist los mit der woche
wird in kiel bekommen ich hab in kiel
bekommen heißt ich hab dirigent fünf
drin und dementsprechend wer jetzt essen
wieder ein paar neue geklatscht so zeigt
zack zack
er ist auch dort welche sportart machst
du früher gemacht fragt kano vorlagen
ich hab früher fußball gespielt sehr
lange fünf jahre vermisst habe ich lange
gespielt auch ziemlich gerne aber das
hat alle alles irgendwie so aufgehört
irgendwann genau auf fußball habe ich
damals wegen der verletzung aufgehalten
habe ich sogar jetzt geht es schon raus
kommt abwehrende jetzt der den killer
verfahren den kill ab ankommen alter
junge aber gut das geile zeit durch das
fahrzeug kann man immer easy weglaufen
wer war auf youtube schon immer ein
vorbild fragt woran die also ich muss
sagen ich habe immer bewundert wie ist
simon also ohne ungespielt ungefähr im
bordell war einfach immer seine
täglichen uploads durchgezogen aber
wirklich jeden tag hochgeladen hat also
da gab sie glaube ich ganz wenige
ausnahmen
ich habe ihn nie so wirklich intensiv
verfolgt also ich war nie als zuschauer
und fan von ihm
aber ich war als creator quasi ein fan
von ihm
weil es einfach geil fand wie er das
hinbekommen hat immer so viel jeden tag
diese disziplin zu haben und das ist für
mich schon was krasses weil ich selbst
ein besonders disziplinierter mensch bin
bald ab was holy cow wie schnell der
down gegangen jetzt jetzt haben wir die
auswahl war ein schaf das heißt ich gebe
immer mehr schiffe immer zwischen zwei
und drei haye geht dann immer jetzt mit
mit fire is back einen hit bis er brennt
und dann mit dem schaf das nach das wird
ein guter kampf hat keine chance bei dem
equipment gar keine
was war dein schlimmster albtraum
schwierig ich hab immer ich habe grasser
albträume teilweise ich weiß auch gar
nicht warum ich in meinem alter noch
albträume hat
vielleicht ist es eine gute sache
gleichzeitig ist das meine fantasie noch
aktiv ist machst du ein traum reiseziel
wurde unbedingt hin möchtest wenn ja
welches fragt silberkurs 14 nochmal
würde gern mal nach hawaii gehen ich
gesagt habe finde ich irgendwie so
hauptsächlich wegen der musik video aber
guckt jetzt gebe ich hiermit und damit
mit dem scharfes nachgezogen
jetzt wieder eine tier mit um mit dem
status nachgezogen keine chance alltag
erst instant da und hast du francisco
anzufangen
momentan nicht obwohl mir alle raten
dass man das zu machen habe ich auch ein
paar und musste nicht schlafen
eigentlich schon ich werde heute früh
schlafen gehen ich schaff's heute
vielleicht tatsächlich immer schlafen zu
gehen
bis dahin
haut rein macht's gut und tschüss